هذا ونقل مراسل اكسيوس عن المسؤول
الاسرائيليه قوله ان نتنياهو سيقترح عده
اجراءات تصاعديه ضد الفلسطينيين خلال
الاجتماع الحكومي اليوم لوقف الهجمات في
القدس واوضح المسؤول ان نتنياهو سيقترح
تعزيز القانوني ترحيلي عائلات المنفذي
العمليات واعتقالهم وغلق منازلهم كما اضاف
المسؤول الاسرائيلي لمراسل اكسيوس ان
نتنياهو سيطالب بالاسراع في منح تراخيص
حمل السلاح للاسرائيل
مباشره الى القدس
ومن رام الله مراسل العربيه عبد الحفيظ
جعوان ابدا معك زياد اخر التطورات زياده
وهل يمكن ان نستشف منذ الان طبيعه
القرارات التي ستتخدمه
بدون مشاكل في اخر التطورات طبعا وصول
وزير دفاع اسرائيل الى تل ابيب قادما من
واشنطن بعد انقطع زيارته الى هناك بعد اقل
من ساعه سيجري مشاورات امنيه مع رئيس هيئه
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي وقاده الاجهزه
الامنيه للبحث في سبل مواجهه التصعيد
الحاصل قبل الاجتماع الذي سيعقد بعد ذائب
عند الثامنه مساء السادسه مساء هذا اليوم
للحكومه الامنيه المصغره همم في مخصص
السؤال حول القرارات الواضح بان اسرائيل
شبه عاجز في مواجهه العمليات الفرديه وهذا
يستشف من هذه القرارات التي جرت تسريب
طبعا ليس لاكسوس فقط وزعت لكل المراسلين
اليوم هذه هذه التسريبات بان نتنياهو
يحاول تمرير قضيه همم تسريع تسليح
ثقيل تسريح همم تسليح المستوطنين
والمواطنين في اسرائيل
وابعاد العائلات عائلات منافذين عمليات
همم من الداخل ومن القدس
وجراءات سريعه مثل هدم او سد منازل
العائلات ايضا طبعا المستشار القضائيه
للحكومه دائما كانت تعارض هذه الاجراءات
المتصله مثلا بابعاد العائلات لانها في
القانون الدولي جريمه حرب وبالتالي ليس
بالسهوله بمكان تنفيذ ذلك وان نفذت
اسرائيل ابعاد اشخاص بمعنى اسرى وما الى
ذلك لكن ابعاد العائلات هذا عمليه نسخ
مكان وجود تحت هلال هذا همم لا يمكن ان
يمر دوليا ايا كان يبدو بان الحكومه
الامنيه تحاول اللحاء للشارع الاسرائيلي
المحتقن عمليا بسبب فقدان الامن همم بانها
تريد ان تتخذ اجراءات وقرارات ولكن كما
قلنا عمليات فرديه ذئاب فر لا قبل
للحكومه بمواجهه ذلك رايت اليوم فتا في ال
13 من العمر يفتح النار ويصيب ضابطا
اسرائيليا ومستوطنا بهذا المعنى هناك
صعوبه جنه في مواجهه هذا الامر على الارض
طيب زياد قبل ان انتقل الى عبد الحفيظ هل
من احتمالات
همم ان تقوم اسرائيل بعمليه عسكريه محدوده
في الضفه او عمليه تبول كما حدث في اقتحام
الدموي لمخيم جنين ام لا هذا مستعد
لا هذا يبقى واردا حقيقه
ربما فقط الجداول الزمنيه ضيقه جدا للتحرك
الحكومه للتذكير لا احد يصل الى المنطقه
بلانكن وزير خارجيه امريكا ولا يسود
الاعتقاد على نحو واسع بن اسرائيل تريد
انفجار الوضع تماما بينما يكون هنا
وبالتالي هذا الامر ربما يؤثر ولكن بدون
ان شك اقتحام لمخيم جنين او نابلس شمال
الضفه الغربيه المحتله يبقى امرا واردا
هناك ايضا همم دفع من بعد الوزراء
المتطرفين تجاه ان تكون همم فاتوره الثمن
بين الزوجين كما يسمون ذلك من قطاع غزه
بمعنى الرد بغارات على همم قطاع غزه لكن
علينا بشير اخيرا قبل ان تنتقل لزميل عبد
الحفيظ لان هذه الحكومه الامنيه اليوم
التي تجتمع الى اا خبره عسكريه واهميه
معظم وزراء وعمليه ليس لديهم هذه الخبره
مثلا بين كبير وزير الامن الداخلي لم يخدم
يوما واحدا في الجيش الاسرائيلي وكذا ايضا
سموترتش وزير الماليه والوزير في وزاره
الدفاع طيب لانتقل الى عبد الحفيظ ابقى مع
زياد لو سمحت عبد الحفيظ جديد المواقف همم
من عندك ايضا وما الذي ينتظره الفلسطينيون
هل تمت مخاوف من عمليه عسكريه سواء واسعه
النطاق او محدوده في الساعات او الايام
المقبله كما حدث في جيني
هذا ما يخشاه الفلسطينيون الطالب هذه
الايام يخشوا ان تصب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
جاما غضبها وفشلها في وقف العمليات في
القدس او في الداخل في هذا تلك العمليات
الفرديه ان يكون الثمن عمليات عسكريه
واسعه في الضفه الغربيه كما حدث في جنين
قبل يومين يخشى الفلسطينيون ان يكون هناك
توغل في المدن الفلسطينيه لتنفيذ ما قاله
بن جبير يوم امس وعد به المستوطنون موضوع
رد الاعتبار للمستوطنين وبالتالي هناك
تحذيرات من السلطه الفلسطينيه التي اجتمعت
هذا اليوم وقالت نحن نحمل اسرائيل تداعيات
كل ما يجري ونحذر الحكومه الاسرائيليه من
ان تقدم على مثل هذه العمليات داخل المدن
الفلسطينيه
والمقلق ايضا هو ما تسرب ايضا قبل قليل
مراسل يدعوه احرنت نقل انها ليس كتيبه
واحده التي سينشرها الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه وانما حديث عن ثلاثه كتائب
سوف تنتشر في الضفه الغربيه على تخوم
المدن فلسطينيه وسوف تعمل لمواجهه
الفلسطينيين همم ميدانيا ما زالت يعني
هناك تظاهرات وهناك مواجهات في مختلف
المناطق الفلسطينيه هي ليستثنائيه يعني
بدانا نشهد مثل هذه المواجهات يوميا
وتحديدا في قرى جنوب نابلس حيث اا يعني
مواجهه مباشره مع المستوطنين ومع القوات
الاسرائيليه هناك ايضا جنوب مدينه رام
الله عند قلنديا بلده الرام وايضا في
بلدات القدس هناك مواجهات متواصله همم
اسرائيل تتحدث عن عمل 13 عمليه اطلاق نار
تعرضت لها القوات الاسرائيليه يوم امس
وتحديدا ااه قرب مدينه نابلس همم وايضا
قرب مدينه رام الله مجموعات عرين الاسود
في نابلس اعلنت عن تبنيها مثل هذه
العمليات عمليات اطلاق النار ايضا كان
هناك مؤتمر الصحفي لكتائب شهداء الاقصى في
جنين هذا اليوم والتي ايضا قالت انها سوف
تواصل همم عمليتها العسكريه ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه وبالتالي ما يخشاه الفلسطينيون
همم ان تصب الحكومه الاسرائيليه اتجاه
غضبها عليهم بعمليات عسكريه ويخشون ايضا
عمليات انتقاميه من المستوطنين وبالتالي
كان هناك تحذيرات لتنقل الفلسطينيين اثناء
الليل بين المدن الفلسطينيه المختلفه من
رام الله مراسل العربيه عبد الحفيظ جعوان
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه ايضا
شكرا لزياد حلبي كان معي من القدس